[Applauso]
sapete cosa significa
artista io l'ho scoperto da poco
l'artix in latino era colui che
praticava qualche arte e la parola Ars
indicava ogni abilità acquisita
attraverso lo studio con la pratica in
contrapposizione a ciò che invece ci è
naturale quindi era Ars ogni cosa che si
doveva imparare
E ma allora Io sono un artista
e scusate allora scrivo poesie canzoni
romanzi commedia faccio il formatore lo
speaker radio il giornalista e quando
tempo inventeremo per la settimana
enigmistica
Sì lo so adesso sicuro di voi vorrebbe
aggiungere un sentito questi Wow
vorrebbe aggiungere qualcosa a questo
elenco no tipo fenomeno meganomane eh in
sano portatori di autostima egocentrico
Ma io non vi ho detto la cosa più
importante
in nessuna di queste attività Io mai
raggiunto livelli di eccellenza
Sì perché per essere felice realizzati
non è proprio sempre sempre sempre
necessario accendere
l'eccellenza la ricerca della perfezione
sono sovrastimate nella nostra società è
troppo spesso considerate l'unico
indicatore di successo ora non c'è
dubbio Eh che raggiungere il successo
l'eccellenza porti gratificazione
realizzazione perché no ci Renda Felici
ma nel contempo limita certe passioni ed
energie che sentiamo spingere dentro di
noi
non vi hanno mai detto a un certo punto
della tua vita devi concentrarti su
qualcosa
È ora di crescere
che cosa vuoi fare della tua vita Devi
trovare la tua strada
la strada la strada Ma chi l'ha detto
che la strada deve essere per forza una
Vuoi vedere che l'uso sbagliato di un
singolare ha creato il più grosso degli
equivoci oltretutto la domanda da fare
Doveva essere un'altra che cosa ti fa
stare bene Perché alcune persone sono
portate ad eccellere in un singolo
ambito altre no
magari molti di noi hanno sempre vissuto
quelli irrequietezza di fondo che ci
spingeva a fare mille cose diverse come
un limite invece di considerare ciò che
era una preziosissima risorsa
sono semplicemente due approcci diversi
Allora immaginate il cammino per
l'eccellenza come un enorme autostrada
a3-4 corsie siamo d'accordo che
l'autostrada probabilmente il modo più
veloce ed efficace di raggiungere la
nostra meta
Ma cosa ci ricordiamo poi del viaggio
magari qualche momento significativo
però il più delle volte
poco nulla
viceversa percorrere le strade statali
laterali Beh ci dà la possibilità di
fermarci fare deviazioni scoprire ed è
molto più facile che sia un viaggio
indimenticabile
e nel nostro viaggio della vita eh
Quanti piccoli paesi abbiamo lasciato
passare quante cose che ci piacevano
abbiamo abbandonato perché magari non
avevamo tempo o non erano in linea col
nostro obiettivo quanto l'aspettativa di
essere eccellenti a frenato la nostra
voglia di Scoprire cose nuove
a quanti bivi abbiamo tirato dritto
ora
Provate a immaginare di salire
in soffitta
la vostra soffitta
e scorgere un angolo buio una batteria
smontata una chitarra impolverata degli
acquarelli e dei pennelli rinsecchiti un
kimono spiegazzato
un diario dalle pagine ingiallite o
qualcos'altro che per voi è stato
prezioso
tutte cose che a un certo punto sono
state lasciate lì magari all'inizio per
poco
e poi per sempre
ed è curioso se ci pensate perché
normalmente noi nella vita noi tendiamo
a differenziare per limitare il rischio
vi faccio un esempio se vogliamo far
fruttare i nostri risparmi fortunati che
ne hanno probabilmente faremo
investimenti diversificati e se andiamo
a giocare al casinò difficilmente
punteremo tutto quello che abbiamo
appena entrati con uno Lean sul rosso e
nero giusto quasi mai puntiamo tutto su
un unico obiettivo tre anni in amore
O almeno è quello che dichiariamo
Ma esiste anche un approccio diverso
immaginate di poggiare una scala al
suolo ed iniziare a salire puntando al
cielo
man mano che ci avviciniamo al nostro
obiettivo
iniziamo Però contemporaneamente anche a
perdere contatto con la dimensione della
Terra e della realtà e siamo sempre più
lontani
viceversa muovendoci in orizzontale noi
possiamo fare tanta strada anche il cibo
del mondo senza Mai perdere contatto con
la realtà E saranno tutti occasioni per
scoprire conoscere condividere
informazioni ed esperienze con
tantissime persone in orizzontale ogni
direzione ha valore di esperienze di
crescita
dal verticale rischi di trovarti in cima
alla scala un po' più solo
e poi il cammino per l'eccellenza non è
leggero per definizione Anche perché una
volta arrivati in vetta ammesso di
riuscirci
inizia una seconda sfida che sarà quella
di rimanerci e anche una piccola discesa
rischia di essere vissuta come un
fallimento
e poi ci sono gli errori gli errori
capitano Ma nell'orizzontale l'errore
spesso si traduce in una piccola caduta
facilmente gestibile Perché la nostra
polivalenza ci avrà permesso di
costruire tutto intorno numerose reti di
protezione nelle quali cadere
una caduta dall'alto invece
potenzialmente un po' più dolorosa e
difficile da assorbire
e poi il numero uno da chi impara
No perché c'è una frase che sentite
spesso che dice se sei in una stanza in
cui sei quello che ne sa più di tutti
sei nella stanza sbagliata Attenzione è
perché questa espressione non è che
vanno proprio presa la lettera perché se
no quello che ne sa più di tutti esce
dalla stanza giusto il secondo che ne
sapeva più di tutti diventa quello che
ne sa più di tutti ed esce anche lui e
il terzo che era diventato secondo
diventato lui Insomma dopo due minuti
nella stanza non rimarrà nessuno o forse
una persona sola
ce lo imparerà nulla da nessuno e
rischiara anche di sentirsi Un po'
stupida ma noi siamo molti Estense noi
siamo depositari di molteplici Talenti
siamo in grado di vivere con le nostre
numerose qualità e se ci abituiamo ad
apprendere sempre cose nuove pena la
nostra mente diventerà più flessibile
più rapida nell'apprendimento perché
sarà abituata a farlo e non è possibile
cogliere ciò che accade intorno a noi se
non abbiamo occhi attenti vigile
numerosi su ciò che ci circonda La
polivalenza leggera e la mia risposta in
orizzontale abbiamo tutto lì vicino a
mano dall'alto devi prima scendere
anche la natura tende a ragionare in
orizzontale
se avete avuto la fortuna di vedere una
cucciolata di animali Beh avete potuto
notare come all'inizio della loro vita
dopo le prime due o tre settimane i
cuccioli iniziano a esplorare il mondo
che li circonda con un movimento
cosiddetto a Stella dove la madre
costituisce il centro il punto di
riferimento I cuccioli scelgono una
direzione verso la palla allontanarsi e
poi tornano da lei in cerca di
protezione e subito dopo ne scelgono
un'altra e poi tornano al centro e così
via
e io mi sono sempre detto ma questo
approccio la polivalenza orizzontale
ce l'ho solo io
Poi un giorno per caso ho trovato un
insospettabile quanto prestigioso
collega di visione in stiva in Hopkins
il famoso fisico recentemente scomparso
Ho letto la sua storia ho detto siamo
simili
ci assomigliamo
risatine non mi sembrano
lui si è laureato giovanissimo
con lode
è diventato nel menu scienziato
e voleva lasciare in eredità al genere
umano una scoperta in grado di cambiare
il mondo
Ok Touché Grazie per
qualcuno
potrebbe obiettare che lui aveva una
situazione diversa e in effetti a un
certo momento lui cambia approccio a un
certo momento della sua vita proprio
quando gli fu diagnosticata una grave
malattia neurodegenerativa lui capì che
probabilmente non avrebbe avuto tutto il
tempo che gli serviva capì che rischiava
di non arrivare in fondo la sua
autostrada e così cambiò approccio
perché puntare tutto su un unico
progetto era troppo rischioso
decise di aprire contemporaneamente
diverse strade molteplici ipotesi
sperimentare nuove teorie in campi
diversi
sapeva che anche così probabilmente non
avrebbe potuto vedere il frutto del suo
lavoro ma nel contempo sapeva che altri
dopo di lui avrebbero potuto percorrere
sentieri già tracciati e magari loro si
giungere le scoperte sensazionali alle
cui anelava
e aveva ragione una sua teoria del 1971
sui buchi neri è stata verificata tre
anni dopo la sua morte
Sì lo so Lui è stato mosso dalla
consapevolezza di avere un tempo
limitato
fra tutti noi abbiamo un tempo limitato
solo che non sappiamo quanto
per cui probabilmente sarebbe il caso di
chiederci se lo stiamo usando al meglio
questo tempo usandolo per farne cose che
ci fanno stare bene perché signori
esiste anche un mondo in cui
l'eccellenza non è l'unico indicatore di
successo un mondo Qui si possono vivere
le cose con pienezza e leggerezza senza
eccessive tensioni e godersi appieno
licket nunc il qui e ora
con un approccio orizzontale è più
leggero un modo diverso di essere
eccellenti
per cui la domanda da fare è
togliamo nella nostra soffitta
ai nostri strumenti impolverati a quelle
pagine ingiallite ai nostri oggetti
abbandonati
come sarebbe cambiata la nostra vita se
avessimo continuato a suonare a ballare
a dipingere a cantare
questo non lo sapremo mai
tra una cosa la sappiamo che non è mai
troppo tardi per riprendere il viaggio
uscire dall'autostrada al primo casello
e iniziare a esplorare Conoscere e
scoprire e fare esperienze Quindi vi
chiedo che cosa faremo di nuovo da
domani come torneremo ad essere artisti
[Applauso]
[Musica]